[Music]
as dawn
breaks over athens phidias is already
late for work
the year is 432 bce and he's the
architectone
or chief builder for the parthenon
athens newest and largest temple
when completed his masterpiece will be
an enormous shrine to the goddess athena
and a testament to the glory of the
athenians
but when he arrives on site he finds
five epistati
or city officials waiting to confront
him they accuse phidias of embezzling
gold designated for the temple's sacred
central statue
he has until sundown to provide all the
temple's expenses
and account for every flake of gold or
face the judgment of the courts though
he's insulted by these false charges
fideos isn't surprised pericles
the politician who commissioned the
parthenon has many enemies in city
government
and this project is somewhat
controversial
the public is expecting a classic temple
in the doric style
simple columns supporting a horizontal
entablature
crowned with a triangular roof but
phidias's plans
are far more radical by athenian
standards
his designs combine doric columns with a
sweeping ionic freeze
hosting a vast panorama of the city's
great panathenaic festival
not only will this sculpture show humans
and gods
side by side something never before seen
in a temple's decor it will also cost
much more
than the traditional approach praying to
the gods that his colleagues
have been keeping track of their
spending fides sets off to prove his
innocence
first he checks in with his architects
ectinos and calicrates
rather than using a blueprint they pour
over the cingraphae or
general plan and paradigma a 3d model
without an exact blueprint the team
often has to resolve
issues in real time guided only by
careful calculation
and their instinct for symmetry
maintaining this symmetry has proven
especially difficult
the parthenon is built on a curve with
the columns
leaning slightly inwards to project
strength and potentially
keep the columns looking straight from a
distance the architects
incorporated entities or slight
bulging in each column for the temple's
other elements
the team calculates symmetry by
employing relatively consistent
proportions
across the design but their shifting
plans require
constant recalculations after helping
solve one such computation videos
collects his colleagues gold records
and heads off to receive a special
delivery
immense marble blocks for the
parthenon's pediment
have just arrived from quarries at mount
pentelicon
the usual ramps would collapse under the
weight of these
two to three ton stone blocks sophidius
orders the construction
of new pulleys after recording the
additional expense
and supervising the construction all
afternoon he finally arrives at the
sculpture workshop
his sculptors are carving 92 mythical
scenes
or metapees to decorate the temple
every carving depicts fighting from
different epic battles
each a mythical representation of
greece's victory over
persia about 40 years earlier
no temple has ever used so many metapees
before
and each scene adds to the temple's
ballooning expenses
finally phidias turns to his primary
responsibility
and the focal point of the entire temple
covered in thick layers of gold minutely
decorated
and towering above her worshippers this
will be a statue
of the city's patron and protector
athena parthenos
when the temple is complete throngs will
gather on its perimeter
offering prayers performing sacrifices
and
pouring libations for the goddess of
wisdom
phidias spends the rest of the day
designing finishing touches for the
statue
and as the light fades the epistatae
arrived to confront him
after looming over his records they look
up
triumphantly phidious may have accounted
for the temple's general spending
but his records show no mention of the
statue's gold
at that moment pericles himself arrives
to save his chief builder
the temple's sponsor tells them that all
the gold on the statue can be removed
and weighed individually
to prove phidias's innocence assigning
laborers to the task
and charging the officials to watch them
late into the night
videos and his patron leave their
adversaries to the
mercy of mighty athena
so that's how things got done on the
acropolis
but what about in the rest of town check
out this video
to get a glimpse of civic life in
ancient athens
or learn about one of the most
controversial buildings
in history